Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Toilet Escape.
Now get ready for a horror adventure unlike any other
It's my personal opinion
that pretty much anything can be terrifying
Given the right circumstances
I-I-It's just that I so happen to have my opinion be wrong a lot of the time
Collect all 5 toilets and find the exit. Press shift to run.
(drip)
Ahright y'know what, I am going to give it the benefit of the doubt! I am not gonna bad-
Woah! What the fuck.
Run
Do I need to run?
(drip) (this continually happens in the background)
(drip)
Fffflush
O-O-Oh noooooooo-ha-ha-oooo
Oh NOOOOOooooo
What do I need to run from? I know I need to get-
I know I need to get that toilet back there, but why?
Why do I need to get the toilet?
Why am I in this place?!
Why am I in bathroom hell?
The-
The eyeeeeesss?
The Eyeee-he-he-hess
What the fuck does that mean?
Alright, I'ma'na go back and I'm gonna  try to get the- oh shit
heay
hoop
woh
Alright then, this was a goddamn dead end.
Alright, so I need to go back and I need to go get the toilets
Because apparently a-
the fuck.
Whoooooaaaa what the fuuucking fuck..?
oh.
no? yes?
no?
well!
Oh no, that was nothing.
I thought that that was actually something for a second there.
Well, I-I think I almost died.
(*distorted female voice*) There is no escape.
WHY?!
Why is there no escape?!
why am I actually kinda creeped out by this?
even though I'm trying to get fucking toileeeettttts?
Alright, you know what. I shouldn't put so much pessimism into this.
I gotta actually believe.
I gotta believe in the purpose.
haha- gotta believe in the heart of the toilet.
gotta believe in the heart of the cards
oh boy oh boy
Ooohhh... Great. Oh good..
(*distorted female voice*) You can run, but you can't hide.
well i mean i could try to hide in one
of the cubicles. You have to knock before
you enter that's only polite and then I
could probably try to hide in the toilet
even though i don't know how i'm hiding the
toilets. what, am I my stuffing these toilets in my pants?
this is like the Slenderman grandfather
clock scenario I'm not fucking by
grabbing that.
The fuck is that sound?
(stepping noises)
What the fuck is that sound?
ok. th-this is where things get legitimately like weird
it's such a strange premise but I'm
actually kind of perturbed by it.
Oh-no
no oh no oh no
Hello? Can you lead me to the toilet please?
I gotta go real bad!
I gotta get the fuck out of here real bad.
oh hello. Ok flush. But, there's no toilet here!
okay well this is a place where a toilet
would be but it's not here yet
I didn't get them in the right sequence
oh boy, that's going to be annoying
Because I have no fucking idea where this place is
oh boy
all right then...... What the fuck is that sound? WHAT THE FUCK!
WHAT the fuck is happening?!
What the fuck was that? I don't know.
God damn dead ends!
what the fuck is happening?
(*distorted female voice*)We will flush you down! (*Mark*)AHFUCK!
I don't know what you're talking about not flushing anything!
holy fucking shit! AH! Fuck!
Ah ok alright that's bad. I was running towards it not
away from it that's why i wasn't getting
any better and my headphones down my face
Ahhh, god run! I am out of run juice.
I am gonna die aren't I? I can't fix my goddamn headphones
eyah, stealth fix! (more mark noises)
Ok, arlight
Well this is, oh well this is a big ol' bag of dicks is it.
the eyes. I'm come back to where I fucking
started. oh great
oh fuck. so I think if i'm not mistaken
I don't know that is! (we will always track you down)
Track me down from what?! How did I end up in this hell? (you can run, but you can't hide)
What kind of toilet based crime did i do?
Jeezuze okay here we go got one. (you can run but you can't hide)
Yeah, don't think i can do either those
I don't have the longevity for it
I have no idea where the fuck I'm going
no idea (there is no escape) i know i know except for the
toy lat
Oh god. I don't know I don't know I don't know I
I don't know. Can't hide. I get that. i'm not
trying to. I'm trying to run like a
scared little baby that I am. If could run
faster i would. i'm limited in my run ability.
oh, is that a toylat? That's a toylat!
ok so if I get this one now then I know
where the last one is I've seen it
before so I can get back to some sort of
landmark, then I might be able to worm my
way back (we will flush you down!) Noo, don't flush me down!
Yo, ho don't flush this boy down!
(we will always track you down) AH! (There is no way out)
Sorry! I can't run! Now would be the time to run! AH!
big glowing turd monster
yeah hey oh god am I going toward a dead end or
I fucking fuck
no no no no you can't flush me down
oh fuck oh fuck oh fuck oh go please go
breathe and run
please don't let me go down the goddamn
dead end. Oh fuck. Breath and run okay no escape.
that's fine! Oh my god how many of you are there (multiple of their taunts sound)
oh fuck did I just-
yes I got all five! I got five you can't
say i didn't! Can you a give me some privacy here?
Ay! fucking. What the fucking fuck?
Oh
hey o oh come on! I got all five!
I got five! I got all five! That's bullshit.
Okay I don't know what's going on she was
standing there. She was being polite
She was waiting until I was done. I get that, that's--
that's understandable. I appreciate that.
oh and find the exit oh ok alright then fine
Then fine. I get it I can't hide from us
I don't remember where to go ok so maybe
maybe it's like the strategy where if
you look at her him/her I don't know
what but if you look at them they can't
move? Got two. (We will always track you down)
ok you try that. See how that works out
for you huh
go to track me down by the smell alone
huh! I get you. I see how you operate.
Yoah. Way ok, so that is how it works
I look at you and you can't move that's
handy-dandy the future but i have no
idea where I'm going to yo yo yo
oh this is a dead end, oh ok.
ah this is not good don't move!
Don't move! Don't move! Don't move!
You're very lovely and i'm sorry if i'm in the
ladies room but- oh fuck you fuck you. Oh fuck.
She's a little speedy. She's a little speedy that one. She's a little bit speedy.
Can't escape. I know that.
I know. I know. I know. (You can run, but you can't hide)
to do either of those things
stop Jesus like the slender lady (We will flush you down)
god dammit i'm stuck in a goddamn loop
here but you have to do with the toilets?
Why toilets?
Woo. Exit? Exit! But I don't have all the toilets!
I can't do this! Well I found the
fucking exit
God damn how did anybody find that shit but
can't get through! Not enough toilets!
Where the fuck? Oh wayyy, she's unhappy!(We will flush you down!)
Woah she was unhappy. woah boy ok alright then woah boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy growin' boy
growing boy needs his toilets!
Ok I am trying to remember the landmark here but
it's a little bit difficult when I got her
breathing down my butt. They're very upset
about something or other and I'm trying
to quell her but it's not not happening
well hello yee-ha fuck. God damn it.
the toilets are a little randomly
generated ok because there wasn't one
there before now there is one. Oh come on!
Oh come on! Oh come on! this bullshit. Ahh.
Oh well apparently I'm not leet
enough to get to the end of toilet escape
I- I thought this was going to be a
really short game, but I literally don't have
any more time to get to the end again.
I got 5 toilets!
Why was I getting toilets, why was I in
this world. It was just a endless hallway of
bathrooms getting toilets being chased
by the slender woman. There is a lot of
puzzle pieces and I can't fit the big picture!
Man, I have no idea, but if you guys
can figure it out maybe the ending gives
you some sort of, like, holistic view of
everything and it's like some small key.
It's like the box for five nights at Freddy's
open and everything is like oh you open
the lid on the toilet and then the
golden glow shines in front of you(trails off into laughter) Oh that sounds horrible.
nevermind let's ignore that I said that
at all but some things are just better
laid to rest so anyway that was toilet
escape that was actually pretty fun it
did scare me for a bit like legitimately
it scared me but the scares went away
pretty quickly
So either way, thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of this down in the comments below and I
challenge someone beat this game.
I put a link to it in the description, but beat this game
and let us know let us all know we all
want to know what the hell is at the end
of this game so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video (outro music starts) bye bye!
(outro music)